he is the head coach of Notre Dame he's
Marcus Freeman former player at Ohio
State Paulie with his new drum roll I
like it and let's welcome in Marcus
Freeman Notre Dame head football coach
here he goes looks like let's
go looks like he got in
a
who w
wow with the snow wow
wow coach coach went right by will I
didn't see his hand I missed it I missed
it oh you missed it uhhuh is is it
because he's rooting for Navy he hates
Notre Dame is that why that that was
just an accident to each their own you
know to each their own to each their own
but I just happened to miss your hand
I'm sorry okay all good all good we're
all good yeah uh so will I you're not
going to be at the game but he's been at
Notre Dame games before and he's been
yelling uh
at the Brady Quinn Quinn I would I would
comment on how high his he wore his
pants uh in the middle of the game yes
but he will not be there he will not be
there this Saturday okay yeah he's yeah
but but maybe when USC plays Notre Dame
you might be going to that game I might
be coming to that game we have to make
that happen okay and I know you're a USC
fan but we have to get you to Notre Dame
stadium for that game I I I would love
to be there okay and look at that there
we go all right look at at the dreams
look at no no look at what we do we hook
you up Fellowship oh Fellowship is that
what it is fellowship yes uh did you
just arrive this morning yeah we got in
about um 10:00 oh okay yeah you get
sleep no no but this is what we wanted
to do we wanted to fly overnight um and
then once we landed we want to stay up
until tonight and then our kids will be
we're going to practice here this
afternoon and then uh here here's the
question did did you get a workout in
right away I haven't had time yet I will
today okay okay I will today who wants
to play the Marcus Freeman bench press
game uh Todd what do you think is what
one
rep 315 315 okay uh c o Conor we go 325
325 all right Marvin I'm going go 350
350 all right one rep okay one rep yeah
Paulie H one rep with the guys around
them pumping them up I'm going to go 340
okay 340 and what about you will 135 13
okay just the plates one one plate on
each side he said mine not yours
okay I I can still do 135 I think I
could still do it uh so what is your
what is your best one rep I would say I
could probably go 330 now the last time
I was 3:15 for three okay so I don't
know what that equals out to so 3:30
yeah okay do you lift with your players
um when they're in there I don't lift
with them I can't their workouts are
crazy but oh okay um I make sure they
know I'm working out how is work how
have workouts changed since you played
uh as opposed to what you're asking them
to do now yeah um I I really think it's
evolved I mean there's just been
different styles of of strength coaches
and as you um really become a coach and
you see how important that position is
um it it's been great to to really be a
part of some great strength and
conditioning coaches but that weight
room pushes your culture pushes your
message as a head coach they're with the
strength coaches probably more than they
are with the football coaches and it has
to be important and not only are you
lifting and running in the weight room
but the culture of your program is being
driven every day yeah I wonder about
that though when as a player did you get
yelled at yeah oh yeah now as a coach do
you coach the same way you were coached
um I hope I'm more mature I I hope I
don't do do something just because I saw
somebody else do it but I'm intentional
about the way I coach and and ultimately
it's to get the best out of your players
and there's different ways you can't
coach everybody the same certain guys
need to be yelled at and pushed at and
and encouraged in a loud voice but
encouraged in a voice and some need to
be brought to the side and you need to
talk to them and see you know hey what
you're not doing exactly what we want
how do we get this changed and so here's
what what I want a culture of though is
that when mistakes happen I want them to
look at their coach it could be their
head coach it could be their position
coach I want a culture that when I make
a mistake I can look at my coach and say
coach me make me better so it's our job
to create that culture as coaches that
they're not making mistake and they
instantly go to fear because they're
going to get screamed at it's like coach
me and make me better and that's a
culture we got to create uh help me
understand this that uh you're nine and
five as the head coach so they gave you
that loss in the Fiesta Bowl as the
interim head coach yeah but should I
mean
should you get that loss absolutely
absolutely but you were the interim head
coach I was the head coach for that game
okay cuz if we would have won I would
have won that
kind growing up what did you think of
Notre
Dan um tradition uh but did you like
Notre Dame you know I respected Notre
Dame um but you went to Ohio State yeah
I was from Ohio my father's from
Columbus Ohio um grew up all I did was
watch Ohio State I grew up wanting to be
an Ohio State football player I was able
to go to one game um as a recruit to
Notre Dame uh and and again the
tradition the Excellence that they have
sticks out to in my mind but I was
focused on one school when I was growing
up how involved are you in the uh future
scheduling of games
um I'm I'm involved but it's constantly
changing right I'm involved in the
conversations but there is no clearcut
okay let's schedule out the next 5 years
with the 12 team playoff with the change
of of
conferences the the new deals in terms
of media rights it this is changing
yearly and so I'm involved just because
I want to make sure I know where we're
headed um but I I got so many other
things to worry about Jack swri and and
and the people that make decisions are
going to put us in a position to to have
success I know that but recruiting how
has it changed and now with name image
and likeness and what is impr proper and
what's proper and you know have people
downloaded you on you can do this and
you can't do that yeah I I think the
biggest thing is that you have to
address it the nil is going to be a
topic that that most kids want to
discuss maybe the kids or the parents
and so you got to be able to address it
um in terms of how Notre Dame's compe in
in in the landscape of nil but I still
think that we have to distinguish
ourselves from other schools with our
football Excellence but also our
excellence and education right that's
what makes Notre Dame different is that
we say we're going to sell football
Excellence but the degree you take out
football the degree from Notre Dame is
but how many kids care about that in in
reality Marcus it it's showing them what
the degree does for them like do they
care about getting a Notre Dame degree
maybe not but let me show you what a
Notre Dame education can do for you
beyond the game of football I don't want
to cheat you in the game of football
right so you can't just skip over
development of football right and how
we're going to develop you as a football
player player and the football we're
going to have as a program but let me
show you at some point the game's over I
don't care how old you are I don't know
when it's going to be but it's going to
be over this is what an education at
Notre Dame can truly um open doors to
for you he's Marcus Freeman Notre Dame
head coach they play Navy coming up on
Saturday night yes will
Captain uh coach let me ask what what
scares you about uh the the Navy Squad
when you when you look at them
tactically
yeah yes yeah let's start you want to
start with the dive let's start with the
dive starts with the dive let start with
the dive then the the foundation of
their offense right pitch yeah exactly
right
that that's what it's all about keeps
you gives you nightmares but things
haven't changed there in 50 years have
they with the Naval Academy or Army no I
but I think they've gotten better their
athletes have gotten better but do do
you how would you like to be a wide
receiver at Navy or Army well listen a
couple of them caught some long balls on
us last year so you know listen I listen
I have the respect for
them maybe I should have brought that up
last year to you exactly I have a lot of
respect for him will you guys will will
the two teams do anything kind of
ceremon like will you guys hang out at
all like have a is there like a meal or
anything like that no it's not like a
bowl game situation okay and and I don't
know how many bowl games are still doing
that you know but I know when I was
playing we used to always do it but um
after the game I know we'll both seeing
each other's alma mater you know and and
listen there's a lot of respect I know
that the Notre Dame football program has
for United States Navy right and their
football team and so we don't need to
have dinner with them before so they
understand that they they know we
respect what they do uh is so Sam
Hartman is what a year younger than you
is that no it's two two years years all
right so you got a quarterback who's
24 I mean how much of a luxury is that
as a head coach that he's got all this
experience he's got a 100 touchdown
passes in his career and he transfers in
and now you got a guy who's you know a
mature man yeah there there's there's no
substitution for experience and I don't
care what your profession is you can be
a quarterback you can be the head coach
at Notre Dame there's no substitution
for that experience and so Sam
understands the ups and downs that come
along with playing that position right
and and he is in constant
uh he's he's practicing and playing at a
constant standard like he's never too
high and never too low and so um the
ability to talk to him and and have
conversations with him um that might be
different than some of my other players
right because he has that experience um
and the other thing he brings to our
program other than his talent is the
leadership skills right he he has a true
ability to make those guys around him
better and um he's been a a great
addition for our program do you have a
question for will
I don't know man you know what here's
what I'm an open book book I do it's
more of it's not a question but an ask I
have to get a picture with you cuz my
kids their favorite movie is
Elf well here's the he w't he won't stop
and and acknowledge your kids I blew by
the two sweet little adorable Irish kids
two little boys going buddy that's elf
and he Will's like yeah so what he just
kept kept going I don't I don't got time
kid I don't know what gelic is for I
don't got
time I don't got it uh when's the last
time you hit somebody me yeah do you
miss it I hit my kids every once no no
no like do you tackle I'm not beat like
hold on I'm not saying like do you
tackle your do you ever get in into a
drill and you want to hit somebody with
our no no you know better yeah I'm good
listen I made a decision um
you know it's really starts with my
oldest son so my old oldest son is 16
and he's a wrestler and plays football
and probably about a year ago we were
wrestling and it was one of those ones
that you had to go way too hard to make
sure you didn't get embarrassed and
after that I said I'm good I'm I just I
just I'm not going to lose but I'm not
going to wrestle anymore right and so
the same thing with football like I'm
not going to lose so I'm not going to be
stupid and go out there and and
embarrass myself so how important was
that video video we saw with your your
team when those kids wanted you to be
the head coach and they like it felt
like they were not going to take no for
an answer how important was that moment
for you to see what your impact was on
these these younger kids you know I
think every day you pour everything you
have into your players
and that's my focus every day is to pour
as much as I can to our players but
sometimes things like that help you
reflect and say you know what this is
what it's all about and and that's an a
bigger scale of of text you might get
from a former player it says thanks for
pushing me or coach I love you I'm
having a bad one of my former players
text me just had um his first child and
um thanks for being a great example like
that's the sometimes the reminders that
you that you often get that this is what
it's about it's about pouring into those
kids and so hopefully that video is a
reflection of that is that a bunch of
young people Trust trust who their head
coach is and and um really they
connected with you they connected with
you but you were not a head coach and
sometimes you connect with your position
coach now he's the head coach did you
worry about
changing no like are you the same guy
that that you were before you became a
head coach at the core of my Foundation
I I truly believe I am now are my
responsibilities different absolutely is
my relationship with 120 guys different
yeah do you know everybody's name
absolutely okay absolutely are you sure
they usually put like their names on
their helmets to help you don't they no
I take a lot of pride in that to make
sure when you yell at 853 no no I better
know his name okay all right who who's
53 uh murf murf that's that's what we
call him murf murf he's our one of our
cers big murf he's a senior but coach be
honest you got like five murfs on the
team no no
he's I mean it is Notre Dame yeah
there's a bunch of M listen they might
have nicknames like I might not know
like everyone first middle last name but
I know hey there's only one MF there's
only one MF one murf um maybe you could
show us form tackling uh during the
commercial break and you can use will as
the dummy and and you can get your
picture too let's do that all right I'm
good with uh we'll take a break I'll uh
I'll see you on Saturday night um I'll
be on the side I'm going to split time
on both sides though okay just letting
you know I do respect the Naval Academy
but I did grow up Notre Dame football
fan and you your Alma moer is Dayton and
I'm a Dayton Ohio yeah University of
Dayton that's right yeah absolutely I
got a letter a recruiting letter from
Digger Phelps and he said hey uh you
know alumni in your area uh recommended
you and uh we're uh interested in
recruiting you and then I got another
letter about 2 weeks later saying we're
not interested in recruiting you so
that's that's that's so they saw you
that's as close as I got but uh you know
it was a really important two weeks
there and uh so I I remained a Notre
Dame fan and a friend of digger Phelps
but that's as close as I got uh all
right we'll take a break and uh Notre
Dame will play on NBC coming up on
Saturday night against Navy we're back
after this with our play of the day